[Music]
cory is in little rock hi corey welcome
to the ramsay show what's up
hi gay how are you better than i deserve
how can we help
my name is corey
um i'm 32
and
i
my boss just passed away a couple weeks
ago
and so he left me
some money
and so i'm just trying to really figure
out what i'm supposed to do like my dad
has told me what i need to do but it's
just it's a lot going on and i'm just
trying to because i don't have a job now
since my boss passed away but
boss left you money in his will
yes
wow that's an unusual arrangement
i was his personal assistant for eight
years
okay
yeah so he he did um
he was an oil contractor
and so i did all his
scheduling everything i was
as he used to call me his go-to go-to
gal
all the time so i mean i just kept up
with all his books and everything that
he needed done
and so after i knew he didn't have he
didn't have family then
he did he did
okay so his wife is the one that
actually
called me and let me know that i was
left something oh okay so he didn't
leave everything to you no no no no no
no i'm just trying it's just an unusual
story it's a wonderful story but i'm
trying to understand so the uh how much
did he leave you
1.25
million dollars
yes
wow
oh my god
i i
couldn't vote i couldn't believe
what i mean what was the old guy worth a
billion or something
uh he he he he has a lot i mean several
properties i've
helped him
manage his properties
he would take me on trips with him and
his family my kids he took care of my
kids i mean wow he was an amazing person
wow so are you married
no okay how old are your kiddos
i have a 15-year-old a four-year-old a
three-year-old and 11 month old what was
your income before before you lost your
job
i was making 65 okay 65 000 a year
1.25 million wow and i was pretty much
living paycheck to paycheck doing that i
mean i shouldn't have but
i mean my kids are
i'm doing it on my own so yeah so do you
have any debt currently any consumer
yes i have um student loans and i have
about forty thousand dollars in student
loans
um we're renting an apartment so
just month by month that's twelve
hundred dollars for our rent
and then my car my mom gave me
um her car so i have a 2006 honda
odyssey
museum right
well you're very wise you sound a little
bit overwhelmed by this a little bit
scared
my dad suggested
that i because my boss was very flexible
with my
went because he knew i had kids and
everything so it was a lot i could work
from home doing calls calls and
everything like that i could do a lot of
stuff from home
but now
i don't think if i get another job i
will have that and it's kind of a
viewpoint my dad was looking at so he
was thinking like maybe if i take a
break until my youngest who's 11 month
old starts kindergarten
because right now it would be like
daycare for all of them well minus my 15
year old it would be daycare for all of
them and
he doesn't think that it would be wise
for me to go back to work just yet and
just
use the money
i don't i don't know okay all right well
what what i would suggest you do is that
you build a
um
let me kind of pan back let's just zoom
back for a second from worrying about
uh
what we're doing tomorrow
overall
someone just handed you 1.25 million
dollars to manage
that's your new job
and you don't know how to do it
okay is that right
yes that's why you call me
yeah and that doesn't make you bad it
doesn't make you bad it's just that
you've never managed 1.2 million dollars
before right
no
definitely not so what you do when you
have
a responsibility that large
which is what this is it's not a woohoo
i hit the lottery moment and i don't
hear that in your voice by the way
i hear a little bit of fear a little bit
of grief still from your friend passing
away a little bit of shock and awe which
i have in my voice that you got this
much money from your employer that's
pretty cool
and uh
so
here's what i suggest that people do
you need to a
number one
move
slowly
okay if you feel urgency or someone
pushing you
stop
okay
because where may people make mistakes
when they don't know what they're doing
is they go too fast let's pretend you're
driving a car for the very first time
i took my kid out in the church parking
lot with the jeep and the straight shift
to teach them how to do the strike drive
and to do the straight shift the first
rule is don't even change gears let's
just figure out and move
slowly get in trouble
stop
right and that's what you're going to do
here because it's something you've never
done before
okay
second rule is the bible says in the
multitude of counsel there is safety
so i want you to build your own advisory
group your own board of directors
not to tell you what to do
but to advise you and teach you and then
you decide what to do
okay you got a pencil
yes you ready to write
okay
first thing you need is you need an
investment advisor
click smart vester at
dot ramseysolutions.com you can find one
that we suggest
the second thing you need is a tax
advisor click tax elp ramsey solutions
dot com and find one that you like
the third thing that you need
is sometime in the next year i suspect
you're probably going to buy a home and
pay cash for it an inexpensive home
under two hundred thousand dollars
okay and you're going to need a good
real estate agent that's your third
person on your board on your advisory
board again we've got elps that can sit
down with you and help you with that
you need to make sure you have the right
kinds of insurance in place
so you need an insurance health
insurance anymore there you go you need
insurance in place and you again we've
got elps to help you with insurance
we're not in any of these businesses but
we've got people set up to where you can
form your advisory board and their goal
is not to tell you what to do and your
goal is not to hire a babysitter
you're a grown woman so your goal is to
gather information from advisors and by
which you go slow enough that you learn
and then you make the decisions
okay
and i think you can buy a home for cash
and invest some of this and not have to
go back to work
okay
i can do like my dad said yep
but it's not it's not by using the money
it's by investing the money and using
the money that the investment creates
okay we're not going to use any of the
money
we're going to put it in an investment
and it throws off an income for you to
live on
okay with your investment advisor and
you're going to not need a lot of income
because your house is going to be paid
for and your car is going to be paid for
you're not going to have any debt and
you're going to be on a budget
okay because like i said i was paycheck
to paycheck you're not going to live
paycheck to paycheck anymore you're just
going to tell every dollar what it's
going to do that's coming in you're
gonna have more dollars than you used to
have
okay and i want you to go through ramsey
plus go through financial peace
university and learn how to handle money
i'm gonna pay for that we're gonna give
it to you for a year
because you've got to get up on top of
this thing or you're going to live with
this horrible taste on the back of your
tongue called regret
move slowly and learn and put advisors
in your corner so a couple things in the
news we need to comment on john like
last week we talked about the
government uh basically states attorneys
general several of them banded together
and sued navient for what it may be one
of the largest settlements in u.s
history navient being required to settle
for 1.83 billion dollars
and 95 million of that was uh in
restitution 1.7 billion dollars was in
student loans that had to be forgiven
because they were fraudulently
made or fraudulently managed
and we made a lot of fun with that and
had a lot of fun with that because it's
it's absolutely a bizarre thing that
navient just got
they got clocked i mean they got their
clock cleaned one of the largest
billions and billions and billions
navien's forgiveness is now more than
the federal government's forgiveness of
student loans but they didn't do
anything wrong but they didn't admit
anything wrong now here's what's
ridiculous though okay here's how people
here's how the media
and i swear some of you people
so you would think that the headline
would read
navient
is a fraudulent scumbag
a bunch of trainees yes that rip people
off and the government took them down
instead cnn says more than 400 000
student loan borrowers will get debt
relief from navient what a gift like
navient is just
a charitable organization thank you cnn
for your misleading headline
now when you read down in the cnn
article it actually does say that they
were sued yeah but you know the but the
headline is like navient is a charitable
organization oh you know we just thought
we wanted to help
because we're just those kind of people
in bc navient plans to cancel some
student loan borrowers loan debt i
wonder who qualifies
headline thanks that's awesome navi
isn't that great they're just they're
just the best people
you're losing your mind out there
america
why would nbc and cnn do that you would
think they would take the side of the
consumer and go crooks caught on tape
your loan might be forgiven because they
were sued into oblivion
you know instead it's like navient is
going to help you
it's like
jeez man come on guys you finally get a
real bad guy
yeah and you don't even know what to do
with him
you finally get a bad guy that you
didn't make up you got a real one and
then we let it just roll off
and then this is this is just
so i'm there was a little uh
a kids game
on the internet uh uh an app or uh
i don't even know what it was i think it
was called animal farm okay and you
would build your little farm is that
right james it's called animal farm
you remember what i'm talking about
animal crossing is what we're hearing
crossing or something like that it was
like this empire thing or something but
you built your farm
and you you tilled the farm
and you know you eventually you know and
you made like
pretend internet money that didn't exist
that's what it is
farmville that's what it was called
and your kid could spend you know and
then it got to where you could actually
go on the site and give real money
to get pretend money to buy a pretend
pig
i make my kids go outside and work a
real garden but this is like this is
like a virtual pig it's not a pig okay
it's a virtual pig it's a pretend pig it
doesn't really exist it exists only
on the internet it's not there's no
oinking no bacon gonna happen okay
just a just a it's a virtual
pig it's not real and you could build
your whole farm out with this and it was
all pretend and it was all virtual and
it was a kid's game and so i run into
this guy at an entree leadership event
and i'm like it's him the guy that
created the game no no the kid's 19
years old and his dad's with him and his
older brother who's 26 is there and i'm
like so what kind of a business you all
got well we build um apps for farmville
and i'm like you mean like add-on like
you don't own farmville no but we we
help people
do better at their farm their pretend
farm that's not really there
and i'm like really
and so how much do you make he goes well
i made six million dollars last year
on this app my dad works for me and so
is my older brother he's 19.
and i'm going crazy i thought it was the
neatest
thing that this young entrepreneur could
figure out a way
to sell an app on pigs that aren't
really there and get real money and got
real money
and kids are paying them serious money
to get started what is happening
that's not really there well then it
started occurring to me that we now have
an entire
probably two generations that are raised
up with a screen in front of their face
and to them what's on that screen is as
real as the real thing
when you say virtual to someone my age
it means not real
it's a projection it's sort of it's
virtual it's not if i
virtually made it i didn't make it
okay if i if you know i didn't get there
you know what i'm saying that's the
literal definition only have a million
dollars no you don't it means you don't
and so
um and so that that's uh that means you
have maybe a little bit less but not
quite you know you're not it's not real
you're not there and so when you say
virtual now to this entire two
generations
to them it's very real because they've
lived their entire life in it
and so when meta hits and now we're
selling nfts and
now walmart and nike and
under armour are selling nfts and now
you can
walmart's setting up now for you to have
your
your pretend house it's not really there
it's only on the internet like your
little farmville
and if you want to buy pretend drapes to
go in your pretend house because that's
what virtual means it means pretend not
real it's not really there there's
nothing there it's it's not real it's
virtual
and but now walmart is setting up
appears to be venturing into the
metaverse with plans to create its own
cryptocurrency and collection of nfts
the big box retailer filed several new
trademarks last month that indicates its
intent to make and sell
virtual
goods let me help you with this
virtual goods is an actual oxymoron if
it's a good it's not virtual
and if it's virtual it's not a good a
good this little coffee cup right here
is an actual coffee cup it actually
exists here's some of the goods
including virtual electronics virtual
home decorations virtual toys virtual
sporting goods and so what we've got is
the kids that grew up playing farmville
are now going to virtually furnish their
virtual house at walmart
oh my gosh
while they didn't pay off their student
loans they don't even live in the real
world they virtually live
because it's safer in there inside that
little box than it is out here with the
with the crazy humans with real drapes
that fall off real windows well and try
hanging real drapes that'll help you get
a divorce but yeah exactly just i mean
but these drapes virtually hang
themselves it's happening
this is yeah yeah unless you have to
hire alone is there not a psychological
disorder at play here
dude we we have i'm telling you it's
escape man it's escaping to a fantasy
world checking out of the challenges of
our real world and we're going to a
place where we can control the variables
because we cannot do it in our real life
that's exactly right
and now we're spending money to do it
real real real money for things that
aren't really there there in case
anyone's forgotten we're in not real
money
to the tune of
what 20 25 trillion dollar like yeah
well there's just so virtual that we're
just moving none of it's real anymore
but uh well your generation did that
well that's true my generation did do
that but in the last last 10 years we've
doubled the uh
you know 10-year look back thing that's
going around yeah you doubled the uh
the debt at the government level that's
another discussion but oh my god
this is so this is uh i i rarely speak
saying i'm not saying it's not okay to
play video games and if you want to
spend some money on your video games or
whatever that's fine but when you
psychologically escape to another world
to the point that you don't own real
drapes but you bought grapes in your
pretend house you got issues from
electronic walmart darling it ain't real
sounds like my aunt
i don't even know what
what do you say to this
it's virtual
it's virtually oh it's not real but it's
so interesting because it's the kid made
so much money i'm so enthralled with it
but it's scary about what it means to
about this generation
cynthia is with us cynthia is in des
moines iowa hi cynthia how are you
hi dave doing great
thanks for taking my call sure um i just
have a quick question so
i am on
i am hoping to get onto baby step four
really soon
so my question is around baby step four
um i'm wanting to contribute about 15 to
my 401k right hoping like this next
paycheck or possibly in february
um but i'm noticing that the market is
well it's on the toilet so
should i really contribute at this time
or should i skip it and move on to like
something else or when i was a little
kid my my mama would take us to a store
called kmart
yep and kmart would in the middle of the
day run these little sails they called
them blue light special blue light
special they would turn on a blue light
over the top of the whatever area and uh
you could go over there and get you a
coffee pot on sale or whatever that's
what you're that's what we're having
right now darling this is called a blue
light special you need to buy water it's
on sale buy while it's on sale
okay so bye at the dip okay so you know
why
how old are you
i'm 40-ish okay 48.
own it own it i'm 61. i'm proud of it so
there you go but the uh
yeah so here's the thing uh uh
in 20 years
where do you think an average
of companies that sound like this
apple coca-cola
mcdonald's
boeing
microsoft
home depot
and on average as a group now there'll
be some one or two that fail
but on average as a group an aggregate
of that group 20 years from now are they
going to be worth more or less
well ideally more
well not only ideally there would be
that's what has always happened in
history 100 of the time so far
in the american stock market's history
now obviously the world can fall apart
and we can just blow this whole thing up
called america but if anything stays
similar to what it is
20 years from today it's going to be up
and you will be glad that you bought in
the cold winter of 2022
when the market was freezing to death
and down
because
of whatever was going on out there i
haven't even seen is something going on
how far down is it i don't even look i
dropped 500 points in one day the other
day but it's just it's back and forth
it's out of 30 000. 500 points used to
be a lot it's not anymore but yeah yeah
it's uh ukraine and uh and biden
mumbling and
they can't nobody here you know nobody's
getting uh idea that he's going to do
anything and so the market's just
unstable geopolitical crap always
destabilizes the market it always has
i mean this little thing happens on the
side of the world and
all of a sudden
because people just have this little
black cloud following around on wall
street just waiting for the next thing
waiting on the next bad thing and then
they're psychological as it can be
but uh um bitcoins in half oh god who
knew
who knew that was going to happen
and so anybody with investing wisdom of
more than eight to ten years yeah yeah
that's true but um yeah it's fairly
fairly easy predictor but fairly you
know easy predictor and this is just a
you know
it is a geopolitical driven it's not
economic driven and it's not
profits the profits of the companies
involved have not changed so are they
suddenly worth less right
no they're so worth what they were worth
it's just they're scared they might be
down in the future because of war with
russia or china or destabilization of
the political environment all that kind
of crap
so do i think all that's going to happen
nope
i think there's going to be problems and
there's going to be times when there's
not problems and the market's going to
go up the market's going to go down and
i only people get hurt on a roller
coaster are those that jump off in the
middle of the ride
here's the thing if you provide service
uh to one person you're gonna make
one
dollar or one amount of money if you pre
provide service to
millions of people you're gonna make
millions of dollars
and you didn't steal any of it evil rich
people is a bunch of crap
it's a lie
here's an example my friend mark cuban
and um
i can actually dial mark's phone number
and he actually will answer we have very
short conversations because he and i are
just alike we don't talk on the phone
hey what see
that's it yeah yeah done no i email him
sometimes and he emails me back no yep
or maybe later we'll talk later or
something you know that kind of stuff so
big big deep in in-depth relationship
but uh um
but he has uh to to his credit
billionaire this from uh this is on npr
oh god a billionaire investor and dallas
mavericks owner mark cuban has launched
an online pharmacy for generic drugs
that promises steep discounts over
traditional distributors the mark cuban
cost
plus drug company announced opening its
online pharmacy wednesday the pharmacy
says it will bypass the healthcare
industry middlemen and help consumers
avoid high drug prices by charging
manufacturers prices
plus a flat
15 percent markup and pharmacist fee
all drugs are priced at cost plus 15
percent
sign up and share your thoughts and
experiences with us cuban tweeted last
week
cuban's pharmacy says it will negotiate
drug prices directly with manufacturers
to lower its costs for consumers one
drug for diabetes patients sells for
3.90
for a 30-day supply compared for retail
at 20
a thirty count of um i can't pronounce
it which is used to treat leukemia and
other cancers goes for as low as
seventeen dollars and ten cents at
cuban's pharmacy compared to two
thousand five hundred dollars
instead of seventeen 17
at other pharmacies now cuban's gonna
make another billion doing this
and he will have helped millions and
millions of people
get drugs for seventeen dollars instead
of twenty five hundred dollars
what's evil about this
you literally have a billionaire here
that that by looking at this article
looks like he is attempting to provide a
public good somebody who says i've got
the money and resources i'm sick of
people i know who have lesser
less less economic uh buying power than
i do
not being able to afford their drug i'm
solving this problem and i'm gonna make
a lot of money why why is that i don't
understand the opposing force there yeah
it's it's um if i'm happy you can't be
because you took up because i took up
all the happiness yeah it's like there's
a something like there's a game like
it's a fixed joy
yeah it's a fixed pie if you make a
bunch of money that means someone else
didn't that's not how money works
oh man rabbi lapin says money is more
like candles than cake
if you get a big slice of cake that
means someone else gets a smaller slice
no that's not how money works so it's
more like candles when you light a
candle your candle is not diminished and
you light another candle and you light
another candle and you light another
counter and then you got christmas eve
service oh huh
so this is mark cubans here's a here's
something that just happened just a few
minutes ago
um
i went and
did a
talk with a
guy who owns a couple of car dealerships
in kentucky and met with his team around
the tornado
right he was right on the tornado he
asked me to come up there talk about
crisis talk about stuff talk about
trauma talk about trauma how do we move
past this and his first time his group
got back together and as a part of that
conversation i was asking
individual people what are they what's
what's something that's real and
tangible that's going on in your life
right now somebody stood up and talked
about a problem with their home they
don't have a home yeah and
they just bought a new home and then a
sale of their old home fell through it
was just a mess
and
this owner quietly said he called his
wife and said i'm gonna buy a house
today
and i he didn't elaborate further ended
up buying that house and said i'm gonna
find something good to do with this
house and thought i'll flip it whatever
then somebody in this and when the
tornadoes came through
he was able to provide housing for a
family that's been displaced and now has
the idea of i'm gonna keep this thing
and definitely i can just use this to
serve
because people need a place to stay
whether it's two months five months one
year and now i've got an opportunity to
help them and that's a 30-year game of
somebody who's been stewarding their
money taking care of their people has
got a heart of a servant and now has the
resources to say i'm going to help you
and i'm going to help them i'm going to
serve my community and no one will ever
know this happened because he's not he's
not a billionaire mark cuban he's just
owns a couple of car dealerships in a
small community that just got wiped out
by tornadoes and he's able to help right
he didn't have to call the government he
doesn't have to call any cert he's able
to help and the those stories go untold
day after day minute by minute all
across this country man
so the data actually says
that when your
[ __ ] friend or family member says rich
people are evil
the data actually says that your friend
or relative is a [ __ ] but they're wrong
that's what the data says
it says that guy's a [ __ ] he's just
wrong
and he doesn't know what he's talking
about there's no first-hand knowledge he
has no data to back this up because the
actual data says that there are no more
evil people among rich people than there
are among poor people
turns out there's jerks that have money
and there's jerks that don't and there's
good people that have money and good
people that don't this is the ramsay
show janelle is in cleveland hi janelle
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi george can you hear me okay
absolutely what's up
um
my husband and i are 65
and our kids are 32 and
and
i don't know when to tell them
how much money we have
now
now
[Music]
um
well the only reason i'm hesitating is
because it's
1.5 million
yeah
so are they are they are they
misbehaving
oh no
no why do you why do you think this
knowledge will bring harm
um probably the way i grew up
i didn't know
anything about my parents finances until
i was
gosh probably
my dad died 55 maybe
i mean my parents just never talked
about it i never asked them right
um yeah lots of parents don't talk about
money or sex and then when their
children grow up they're surprised to
find out they had both
well they're both married and my
daughter is having a baby in about three
days so i think she knows about sex
one down one to go i wasn't talking
about her sex i was talking about yours
but yeah i know
oh my gosh
yeah i i think you sit down now
you know when i had this conversation
with ours they were just coming out of
college
i didn't want them i wanted them to have
the maturity to be able to handle the
discussion the emotional and the
spiritual maturity
and uh we're a family of faith and so
the conversation started with this as
for me and my house we serve the lord
and so the information i'm getting ready
to explain to you is not
uh it is not you hitting the lottery
because you are not inheriting the money
you're inheriting the responsibility to
manage the money for god
mm-hmm
and that's how we started the discussion
and that's still how we have the
discussion to this day they've yet to
inherit any money but
but they know they know what our wealth
is in detail and they know exactly
what's going to happen to every penny of
it uh we have a big meeting once a year
with our leadership team at our office
and with our kids and we go over the
real every piece of real estate we go
over
uh you know any of the wealth that is
there and exactly how the wheel remind
everybody how the wheels and the trusts
all work because it's kind of
complicated
and um you know we just have a review of
this and this is a transaction
so long ago they got past the emotions
of feeling like they hit the lottery
well i guess i'm wondering why why why
do i
what's the purpose in it because you can
teach them
to have the proper spiritual and
financial stance on this while you're
alive
otherwise you don't know what the
reaction is going to be and if you get a
negative reaction you may want to adjust
some of your inheritance
um
okay
because we i just yeah we don't leave
peop money to people in our family if
they're misbehaving because we don't
want to finance misbehavior with god's
money oh no
no i wouldn't do that i know but how
about their
how about their son-in-laws or our
son-in-law same thing
listen if it's going to affect the if
the information that this money is there
is going to affect them how much more do
you think the money is going to actually
affect them
when it comes out of left field
and there's no time to emotionally
process it oh by the way we're also
processing the death of a loved one at
the same time
hmm
so the so you think the son-in-law
should be included in absolutely
they are at my house
because they may they're they're they're
family
they're not necessarily going to
actually personally get the money but
their spouse is
and so you dadgum right and you get to
speak to all of them about what this
means to you and and how we you think
they ought to view this and that we're
not going to allow you to feel like you
can put co push the car up into neutral
because this is coming you know we can
have all kinds of good discussions
there's all kinds of teachable moments
so george
the producer james just handed us an
article
it's juicy it's a juicy one
well
okay
this pisses me off all right because
the um
consumer financial protection bureau
brought to you by elizabeth warren
that's where it came from
was put in place to protect the consumer
they were put in charge of a piece of
legislation that's been in place for 30
or 40 years
called the federal fair debt collection
practices act
there's federal law that dictates how
collectors have to behave
or they're in violation of federal law
when they're trying to collect from you
the consumer financial protection bureau
is in charge of the federal debt fair
debt collection practices act
regulations and uh fines and you know
you know basically protecting the
consumer
so what did they do
under this administration
decided to
help out the collectors
instead of the consumer
so they just
new rules approved by the consumer
financial protection bureau
that took effect this is from npr that
took effect on tuesday dictate how
collection agencies can email or text
people as well as message them on social
media
to collect unpaid debts so now they can
hassle you on twitter
your facebook account text you and email
you
what part of protection
at the bureau did they not get
they just unleashed the hounds on the
consumer financial protection
bureau you need to read the title of the
place you work
good god i thought it was bad enough
when my mom joined facebook
and now the collectors are on there too
the whole gang
you can't stop everyone's watching you
george
you know a way to fix this is don't be
on facebook
good luck well it's easier now
everyone's going you know they're on
instagram
i have to have something like i got
where i pay people to do this stuff
because i can't stand it but this is
what's crazy it says they can attempt to
join your network by sending you a
friend request and they must give you
the option to opt out of being contacted
online and any messages they send do
have to be private so they're not going
to go posting on your public page dave
don't worry
yeah that would be a violation of
privacy act a whole another act
the rules are really disappointing and
concerning in a number of ways says
april nuhoff a staff attorney for the
national consumer law center hello april
that's an understatement
uh yeah disappointing no this is just
ridiculous this is what we in the south
call we just let the fox in the hen
house that's a good saying i like that
one
here's what's crazy chomp chomp we're
going to see
so much spam come out of this it says
allowing debt collectors to email text
and use social media to contact
consumers also gives criminals a new
avenue to try to swindle people out of
their money a practice kanuhov expects
to increase in the future all right i
get a bunch of crap on my apple phone
updates
that i don't want
and they force it on me and i have to go
in and turn it off or turn it on and so
that people aren't watching me and all
this other bull crap all these things
they do with this technology i'm getting
just paranoid
but they're gonna have to put a thing on
the apple phone
oh yeah block collector text
select
on or off
and maybe you know there you go
that'll work
so um i did just somebody just show me
the damn i'm so technology stu you're
gonna look at me because you know i'm
stupid but um
yeah you can turn off uh not the phone
doesn't ring if it's an unrecognized
number because the 73 000 calls i get a
year on my
warranty for my car that i need to buy
which is hilarious you're calling dave
ramsey's phone i mean come on
but um
yeah i mean all those are blocked now
and so automatically they don't it
doesn't ring my phone so i can we're
going to have that selection of
collectors apple's gonna have to protect
us because the protection bureau won't
protect us oh boy and you know the weird
thing about sliding into the dms here on
on your instagram account if the only
people sliding into the dms are the
collectors that's a sad life we gotta
pay off this debt get rid of it leave
them on red you can't ghost these people
they're going to be after you
that sums it up
travis is going to start the year off
from asheville north carolina travis
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you guys doing today better than
we deserve man what's up
i have a question for you
we are in baby step six
and i made a purchase last month that
i've been losing some sleep about
because i can't decide if i did the
right thing and i tried calling him last
month and you all were super busy so uh
i'm getting through today and either
gonna get a tongue lashing or some
reassurance i'm not sure but i have a
question about a vehicle i bought
okay
um so i was looking for a truck for
months like two or three months i saved
up cash and with this crazy
market um everything that i was seeing
just seemed
really high for a used truck so i kept
looking around and i finally came across
a deal a couple hours for me on the
truck that i wanted and it was actually
a new truck that was going for about
three grand less than the used trucks of
the same year like i was looking at 2019
2020 gmc sierras and they're going for
around 55 grand for the for the truck
that i wanted and i came across a 2021
that was brand new with factory rebates
that had it down to about 52.5 and it
had to make a quick move just because of
this crazy market so long story short i
did end up purchasing it even though it
was new and i know that you know that's
not what we do with the baby steps but
i'm wondering what this crazy market and
the price you know and the research that
i did if if this did make sense or if i
should look to maybe get rid of it and
get into something cheaper
well i have a rule i don't start the
year with tongue license
you caught him on a good day
the first caller of the year we can't do
it it's against one of the rules and so
what so you pay 50 grand for a truck
what do you make of your household
income
150 okay
and what's your net worth today
about 200 okay
all right
and 50 000 of it is in the truck going
down in value
yes
this is why we tell people not to buy
new vehicles
until you have a million dollars
one-fourth of your net worth is going to
be worth nothing in five years
right that's the problem with buying new
trucks i mean
if you're worth a million dollars you
can afford to lose 50 grand if you're
worth 200 000 50 grand a lot of your
life
that's the only point so it's not a ton
lashing it's just an observation
man you're a grown man you make 150 000
a year you can go buy a truck if you
don't go buy a truck we're not gonna be
mad at you we'll still be friends
okay
so again no tongue lashings at the first
year but you're right that's why we
teach people
not to yeah and if i was travis i would
have looked at a car that was you know a
few years older than that and that's
where you are going to find something at
a cheaper price point when you look at a
2021 versus the 2022 and the used car
market right now i get that it's crazy
but i think like you're saying dave this
is just a huge percentage of his world
that's tied up in this depreciating
asset now i mean the thing is this you
need to ask yourself when you're buying
anything with wheels or a motor
if i set fire to it without insurance
after it finishes burning
is my life changed dramatically when you
lose 25 of your net worth if you set
fire to it
that's pretty dramatic
you lose five percent of your net worth
it's not dramatic
it's a ratio thing for me you can do
what you want to do
but as long as you lean into
depreciating assets being a large chunk
of your world things losing value
that are being a large chunk of your
world then you're going to struggle with
that and i did the exact same stuff
travis i mean we've all done it but you
knew better because you'd been taught
and you just figured out a way to
rationalize it well he was saying if he
would call it i wouldn't lose sleep over
it it's not going to cause you to go
bankrupt i'm not going to sit here and
shame you that's not the point the the
point is the reason we teach
not to buy a new car unless you're a
millionaire is this exact reason and it
ca you know it comes from all things
when i got tongue lashed by my grandpa i
mean he passed away now but um you know
he worked 38 years at alcoa aluminum
head cost accountant there in alcoa
tennessee down the mountains east
tennessee and i come wheeling up down
there at
23 years old 24 years old with a million
dollar net worth driving a jaguar
and a bunch of real estate debt coming
out my ears just before i'm going broke
right
and and uh i was all proud of my jaguar
well grandpa from east tennessee didn't
even know what jankwart was he's like
what is his car
and i told him and he's like shaking his
head he was not impressed
and he's like what'd you pay for that
and i told him and he just spit
and he just out of disgust yeah he said
a truck over there didn't cost that and
i'm like no that truck over costs 200
bucks
you know
and it's not a it's not a fine european
automobile
you know so i drove off all
uh
bothered that my grandpa was not
impressed with my proud new purchase
and uh of course when he passed away he
had a million dollars in money markets
um and so and the reason he did was he
didn't put it all in things
he goes i said well this is a great car
so these things hold their value and he
started laughing and he goes ain't
nothing holds his valuable wheels on it
boy
i said what do you mean he goes well it
holds its value he goes he goes so it's
like an investment he goes my
investments go up
yours go down there's a problem with
this formula you're using son did you go
to college or what you know it's that
kind of thing right one of these
conversations with your grandpa right
nothing like that
whip my butt man oh my gosh today's
question comes from laura in tennessee
our family has been a dave ramsey family
i always agreed with the quote expensive
college is a rip-off idea and my older
son is in community college now my
younger son announced at age 7 that he
wanted to become an economist and fix
poverty and wealth inequality almost a
decade later he still wants to become an
economist he wants to go to harvard or
wharton and feel strongly that going to
such a school would help him develop
connections that would allow him to
advance his goals as jobs for economists
are mostly appointed we can afford to
pay his way but is it really worth 250
thousand dollars in tuition alone
hmm
there's a lot going on here i'm
intrigued by it i'd personally this is
my personal take i don't think it's
worth two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to go be an economist for the
connections
but if they have the cash to do it and
that's something they want to do for
their son
that's the decision they can make but
personally if i'm if i'm mom and dad i'm
going no we're not doing this
okay
this kid is obviously a child of great
intellect and he's also a super nerd
yeah seven years old he wanted two seven
years old i want to be an economist and
do away with wealth
inequality what seven-year-old says that
come on strange ones very smart ones
yeah that's an unusual child
and so uh in a good way maybe but maybe
maybe
um
it sounds like you're 17. now the child
is she said almost a decade later so he
must be 17 close to college
a decade so 16 years old okay
let me help you with this at 16 years
old you do not know what you're talking
about
you're so full of crap that it's
unbelievable
i want to go to harvard because i can
make connections because economist jobs
are all appointed
horse crap
you're 16.
you do not know what you're talking
about
you don't know what you're talking about
young child
this is why you have parents thank god
you need parents you need a keeper even
if you're very smart and unusually
bright young man who has had it
focused
since you were a child a little child
but um so here's the thing there are
economists in all parts of life
um i have a friend who is one of the
best known economists in the world he
invented the laffer curve art laffer
he has a phd from economics i believe it
was cambridge if i remember
i served in reagan's cabinet and he
served on the in the trump cabinet as
well wrote the last trump tax law is
absolutely brilliant and made almost
none of his money
doing those things
he instead manages
wealth
for others i'll just leave it at that
and um like lots of wealth with bees on
the end of it billions
and so um and art's like 80 something
years old now he's brilliant he's again
he's a friend he's still a real shy in
the area probably one of the best known
economists on the planet that's alive at
this moment in the top five anyway
and so um
he he would tell you that education is
vital and education is important and he
would tell you cambridge was worth the
money uh because of the path that he
ended up going on
uh but i will tell you that that job
there's only about three of those
in the world
and the rest of time the economist ends
up working for a mutual fund company
or the economist ends up working for a
financial planning company or the
economist ends up working for
a large
corporate
entity that needs some economic
predictions
and models run out on their
revenue projections and an economist and
in all of those cases there's no roi on
what you're talking about
so these schools are not better schools
and no they do not provide better
connections they're just more famous
let me also let me point out to you this
here's an example of what i'm talking
about
wall street journal did a study a few
years ago
and 78
of the forbes
i'm sorry 78 of the s p 500 the 500
largest publicly traded companies
on the stock exchange 78 8 out of 10 of
the ceos graduated from state schools
i'll help you with that again
of the largest 500 companies traded on
the stock exchange
8 out of 10 ceos graduated from
state schools
they went to
the university of fill in the state but
dave they're missing out on the
connections and harvard but they're the
ceo of household name companies
and by the way the cfos same situation
the cos
same situation
the chief digital officers some of them
didn't even graduate from college
and so yes you can get a degree there
but this idea that you the connections
you make in college are going to open
your doors and make you successful is as
dumb as the idea that the degree
is going to make you successful what
makes you successful at the end of the
day is you
education is important it's even vital
but where you get it and who you are
connected to
there is no data to back up this theory
of where you went to school matters
that these prestigious universities that
there's an roi on them we cover a bunch
of this in borrowed future i was just
going to say this is all reminding me
very heavily of the bard future
documentary where we go into this and we
talk about is is school worth it are
degrees worth it what about trade
schools and state schools versus the big
name and what we found out was that
there's there's really no correlation
between success
of hey i went to harvard or i went to a
state school
learn to play golf join a country club
for a tenth of what you would pay at
that school and go get a degree from a
state school and you'll be better off
and if this kid it really has the
intellect that i think he has i think he
can get scholarships they're going to be
knocking at the door trying to get they
can go for free that's fine but that
isn't what she asked we can afford to
pay is it really worth 250 000
no it's not worth a quarter of a million
dollars no it's not no no but is he
smart enough that he's gonna be just
fine and maybe he could be an economist
and love what he does sure yeah but i
wouldn't pay a quarter million dollars
for the pleasure of it yeah and uh
it's uh um but don't just because your
kid has
an unusual proclivity for
articulating his ideas at seven years
old
does not mean he actually knows what
he's talking about
to get poor 17
and sometimes parents get all enamored
with their kids wishes
and um this is why you're supposed to be
parents
and you know it's like i don't know i
had one guy called me for missing he
said my daughter told me she's going to
this expensive school what am i going to
do and i said well you messed up a long
time ago because my daughter didn't tell
me stuff i tell her stuff that's how
that works so that's where we got
confused we got confused how this works
got confused as to who's in charge here
by the way it's my money
so um she's trying to make a decision
you know reasonably and i'm and i'm not
picking on your kid your kid's obviously
a special child in a lot of good ways uh
and that that's all fine but it does not
mean he's wise
and uh so his
opinion about the connections is
something he heard
from somebody or read
with an internet article
this is the ramsay show brandy is with
us in sacramento hi brandi welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave it's so nice to talk to you you
too what's up um
so me and my husband plan on leaving
california in five years when i can
retire early from the state and start
collecting my pension
so we have sold two of our three homes
and have that money just sitting in the
bank
and with interest rates expected to rise
and inflation going through the roof
where should we invest that money for
the next five years we want to have it
you know available when we're ready to
buy out of state yeah but if it were me
i would put a portion of it if not all
of it in just a simple index fund an s p
500 fund
okay
now what that is is a fund that follows
the stock market exactly
it's not going to do better than the
market or worse than the market it's
going to be exactly following the market
now not the dow jones industrial average
but it's going to follow what the real
market is doing the overall markets the
top 500 stocks according to standard and
poor and that's the snp 500 okay
and so i do that when i'm parking money
and uh it's a conservative mid-range
mutual fund investment it's very
predictable
and it has no commissions on it so
you're not going to get you don't you i
don't mind paying a commission when i'm
going long term but when i'm just
sticking in there for a little while and
i'll do that sometimes for a year or two
years not even five but when you do it
for five you're pretty safe because the
market's track record over five year
periods of time is very very good to
make some money and you don't have to
make much here to do better than
the bank because the bank just doesn't
pay anything
yeah
and the good news is you're investing
basically in companies that are
inflation
meaning the the things that they make
and that they provide are the prices are
going up on them so they're reflected in
your returns
so that's what you call a hedge against
inflation when you are investing in the
things that are the elements of
inflation
that make sense yes it does so you know
but now here's the thing you can what
you ought to do is you ought to uh do a
little bit of study on that and see what
the track record is and say okay how
many periods how many five year periods
of the s p
make money and how many lose money
and you go oh whoa you know i could lose
money yeah you could
uh but what's the what's the likelihood
based on that i don't know that number
off the top of my head by the way
um
it's the vast majority make money though
probably ninety percent of the five year
periods make money but ten percent of
the time you could lose money well based
on that i don't wanna put it all in
there i'm gonna put some in cds okay
that's fine but cds are gonna pay you
one two percent even if rates go up and
uh the rates are not going to go up to
the inflationary levels because we're
sitting you know we may see some
double-digit inflation and so if you're
not making at least
10 percent on your money you're not
going to be ahead of inflation
follow me
so it's
you're taking the risk of inflation
kicking your butt if you don't invest
aggressively enough if you invest too
aggressive you're taking the risk of
actually losing the money does that make
sense
yes
so that's that's why i do that's what i
would do with it it's what i do with
mine
uh i just park it there and then any
money that it makes you don't have any
it hardly has any turnover ratio so
there's hardly any taxes on it until you
pull the money out and then if you did
make some money and you pull the money
out it'll be taxed at your capital gains
rate rather than your ordinary income
rate so it's even tax advantaged
in that sense
christina is with us in cedar rapids
iowa hi christina how are you
oh good how are you dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
um so i have a question for you um
we recently paid off over 300 thousand
dollars in student loans wow yeah
christina
yeah it took us about four years i'm a
physician
um
and my question is
i just had my third baby
and
i
feel crazy saying this but i don't want
to return to work
um my husband has always been
supportive and working kind of part-time
jobs while
taking care of the other kids and he
just recently started a full-time job
um at a bank and it's kind of a a trade
they're
training him
while he's there and it would be a major
pay cut for me to quit my job but um
that's kind of what i'm feeling pulled
to do and i just wanted to hear your
thoughts on that
wow
what does that what what is he going to
make at the bank when it's all when the
smoke clears on the train and everything
yeah so they're starting at his job as a
credit analysis and he's kind of a
junior credit analysis so his starting
salary right now is 56 000 a year
um and then they told him as soon as um
he's kind of fully trained
then um it would be
in the 60 to 70 000 um would be like
where he'd start at cool and what do you
make now
me um if i go back to work i'm making
about 190 000 a year
okay
all right so we're dropping our income
120 000 bucks to make this move yeah
um if you go from 190 to 70 i mean of
course if you if you go back to work
it'd actually be 260 because it'd be him
making 70 plus your 190 but but you're
out of debt and you're able to make it
on 70 000
um yeah we um
our only debt is our house um and our
mortgage what we own it right now is
about 95. we live in a kind of a smaller
rural area 95 000
um
we're in our mid-30s and our retirement
we have about 230 000 in retirement
um
are you done with it or could you do
telemedicine two days a week or go in
one day a week i mean are you just
completely
burned i feel really burnt and it's
really hard to
give my all to my husband and my
children when i always have that stress
on me um we did talk about i have
reached out to a couple um
like the ceos at a few smaller rural
hospitals about the possibility of maybe
doing one or two days a week for them
in the future maybe when the baby our
baby gets to be a little older
um but
what have you got to do to keep your
medical license intact
i think i just have to maintain my
continued medical education and my
license which yeah
my experience with doctors who
have a picture in their head about
well let me let's choose separate issues
here one is
um a mom who's like i want to go be with
my kids that's that's
that's noble great wonderful high
support would never tell you not to do
that absolutely awesome
the other side that the doctors that
i've worked with and known over the
years
are just
quite frankly wired differently than the
rest of us
and the thing that drove them to go to
med school and get through med school
and to get through residency and
rotations
is uh there's just a different drive and
i wonder i i've had several buddies who
end up i'm gonna just go i'm gonna quit
all this i'm gonna go do a small
practice
a couple years later they're back doing
a night a week in the er just to get
their blood pumping again right so i
wonder if you've boxed yourself into an
either or right now and maybe you need a
break but that there's some other
opportunities to split the difference
here
okay yeah i i don't care the money thing
doesn't scare me
what i'm thinking about is um
if i were in your shoes
the thing i would struggle with the most
is not i you know yeah i want you to be
with these kids that's what you want to
do let's just let's lay that as the
foundation of the whole discussion um
but you have paid such a price
of uh commitment and diligence to become
a doctor and then as a doctor to pay off
the 300 000 so you literally paid a
price as well
as the as the toll
you have paid to go do nothing with it
for the rest of your life seems extreme
yeah i would agree with that and i think
i think that's what's the hard thing
yeah and i just i think you're going to
struggle with that so i i just from uh
you know i
uh from the standpoint of that i'm going
to stay engaged at a
greatly at a 90 reduced level
or or whatever after the child comes and
after you you know take a normal
maternity leave or whatever but like you
said go hit the rule hospital for a day
or two a week something anything uh or
you know
telemedicine like john suggested
whatever it is you want to do but
something to just keep um
to stay a little bit engaged and the
natural result of that is going to be
100 000 a year probably
okay i mean you know that's that's your
that's irrelevant because you're gonna
make plenty of money but but um i you
know some kind of part-time something
that fits into your new life that you
want to have with these kiddos
but also allows you to
um not just dust
you know shake the dust off your feet
from all of the
the decade of work you've put into
getting to where you are
i'm sure they exist and they can write
in and let me know i've never met a
doctor who walked away and ended up
staying away because they're that's why
they i mean it takes such
uh it's such an identity i'm a helper
that's what i do
it's hard to just walk away from that
completely well there's just an
intellectual and emotional commitment of
time it's a stimulation like the whole
thing yeah the whole thing so anyway yes
i would quit uh doing what you're doing
and so that you can be with your kids
and yes i would try to find some uh
greatly reduced middle ground
uh that you can stand on
because i think you'll be happier uh
because your intellect is gonna require
uh you know you're going from solving
ultra high level problems high level
thinking to can i have a snack can i
have a snack can i have a snack
and
it's not that one is better than the
other one is more noble than the other
that's not the point
the point is your brain is set up in a
certain way now
and it's it's um yeah
you know
a lot of moms of little ones
uh while they want to be full-time moms
they also want to have adult
conversations with adults absolutely
and need it and so that that's that's in
the mix here so yeah that that's but yes
i would quit
don't quit doing what you're doing i
wouldn't work the hours you're working i
would not stay in the 190 position you
don't have to you can make it on the 70
plus whatever little
plus the other 70 that you bring in or
whatever maybe you can match his now
let's let's talk about the person who
hasn't who's in that situation who
hasn't put in the incredible work that
christina put in to get that money paid
off you're stuck you you gotta get
yourself out of debt you gotta get
yourself out of that because you're not
in a position to like you can't lay
under a three hundred thousand dollar
blanket yes uh and wait it'll suffocate
you and sleep you won't be able to sleep
that's right and you won't be able to
prosper your family won't be able to
move forward so you you know you've dug
a hole now you gotta get out right and
then you can talk about doing what she's
doing yeah but christina put in four
years of grinding yes they've been
getting they've been helping man they've
been hitting hard good for you guys
so well done very well done